Kenya was known as the Silicon Savanna,
name coming from the Silicon Valley.
A lot of early adopters
in the tech space started
creating a community and building products
that has now led to the creation
of the African tech space.
After over a decade of development,
Africa's startup scene is booming.
Last year, the tech sector
attracted a record $5 billion,
more than the total amount raised
in the previous three years combined.
It's actually kind of
mind blowing in many ways.
The pace of growth in
the last couple years
is incredible in terms
of the amount of funding
coming into the continent.
And that is particularly
because there was a lot
of interest and excitement
from U.S. investors.
We saw some really scaling
up their investments.
The continent also saw the creation
of a record number of five unicorns
private companies valued over $1 billion.
And this year looks even more promising.
The creation of unicorns
that has more or less
proved to investors that you
can make African tech companies
into multibillion-dollar companies
that are profitable on the continent.
It's a vibrant place to be.
We've got great innovators
and we are beginning to
see that evolve quickly.
But Africa's startup scene
is still much smaller compared
to the rest of the world.
With regulation differences
and income disparities
across the continent, can
African startups keep growing?
When you talk of the
Genesis of tech in Africa,
you'd have to go back.
When government started
promoting the internet
and the use of the internet.
We started to see a pipeline
of software engineers
that came out.
And some of the things
that they started doing
was really making
applications, for instance,
HR management applications for
universities, for hospitals,
for large stores, and factories.
Also in the 1990s, big tech companies
brought cellphones to the continent,
laying foundations for
Africa's mobile internet age.
Kenya has been one of the hubs
leading Africa's tech
innovations since the 2000s.
You can argue that Nairobi is
where Africa's tech started.
So in the late 2000s
with the advent of the sea cables coming
onto the coast of Kenya
and with the availability
of well-educated, young people,
a community was created in Nairobi.
And iHub was one of the
first community spaces
on the continent that brought
innovation groups together.
Founded back in 2010
by a group of like-minded techies,
iHub provided a much-needed
space for entrepreneurs
in Nairobi to meet, share
ideas and develop products.
The first three years of iHub was amazing.
There was this energy that
was on another level of people
to actually chat with each other,
people to build prototypes.
People having hackathons,
hackathons week after week,
just to see who could
develop the best app.
Training is happening.
People giving their time to
train the young developers.
So it was really intense of
how amazing the community was
from all levels, academia from
corporate, from government,
to tech community itself.
We've had hundreds of
startups that came out
of the iHub ecosystem.
Some have actually been very successful.
Since its inception iHub has helped create
150 startups and created
more than 2500 jobs.
Achieving what the Kenyan
government tried to
but couldn't do.
You see world-class office space.
We see launchpads to
extraordinary startups
and profitable organizations.
In 2008, two years before iHub was born,
the state proposed a
plan to build a tech hub
called Konza Technopolis,
about 60 kilometers southeast of Nairobi.
But over a decade later,
the project is still a work in progress.
You cannot force innovation to happen.
It's not just the space that you need.
It's the people that come with it.
It's the talent you need
to build this tech space.
Another milestone in Kenya's tech history
was the birth of M-Pesa,
a mobile phone-based
money transfer service.
It was launched in 2007 by Safaricom,
Kenya's biggest telecom company
partly owned by the UK firm Vodafone.
Like many African countries,
Kenya's banking system
was underdeveloped and a huge
majority of the population
didn't have a bank account.
That meant transferring
money was difficult.
We started with the send
money home proposition,
because Kenya has a
rural to urban migration
and everyone in the urban
areas are sending money
to rural areas.
And that meant taking time
off work or over the weekend
to go see your parents
and give them money.
I remember in 2007, I used to
travel almost 500 kilometers,
from Nairobi to go give my mom money.
Just with the advent of the
send money home proposition,
that changed how we send
money in Kenya dramatically.
But smartphones hadn't
arrived yet in Kenya
and so the M-Pesa team relied
on USSD and SIM toolkit,
the same technology
used for sending an SMS.
Users registered for an M-Pesa
account with their SIM cards,
put cash into the account
through an M-Pesa agent
and then sent the money by phone.
Recipients could also
cash out through an agent.
The transaction fee for sending money
was 30 Kenyan Shillings, about 26 cents.
It went on and was developed
into a complex payment system
where people can not
only just transfer money,
but can also pay bills, borrow.
And they're now even investment
products that are on M-Pesa,
In fact, even the Kenyan
government used the system
to sell bonds at one time.
We have 30 million active customers
on the M-Pesa Kenya ecosystem.
Today, well over 50% of
GDP of Kenya is actually
flowing through it.
The success of M-Pesa
ushered in mobile money
across the continent, spawning
the birth of other startups
trying to solve everyday
problems in Africa.
Among them Sendy, a Nairobi-based
digital logistics company
facilitating door-to-door deliveries
between individuals and businesses.
Logistics in Africa is quite
fragmented and quite costly.
If you have an item on
the shelf about $10,
about four to six dollars
of that is we can attribute
that to logistics, over
40% to 60% of that.
And that's the problem
we sought out to solve,
reduce that to single digit form.
And technology has allowed
companies like Sendy
to aggregate the informal logistics sector
into a more homogenous kind of play
that all these businesses
can actually trade.
When we talk about shipping,
you have to also talk about payments.
We started in Kenya because we kind of saw
how the digital economy
was growing in Kenya.
And the penetration we
had seen in mobile money
in this market enabled us
to move quite fast on that.
2021 was a breakout year
for startups like Sendy.
With the Covid-19 pandemic,
many consumers turned to online services
for grocery deliveries,
tutoring and healthcare.
African startups raised a
record $5 billion last year.
And nearly two-thirds
of the top 20 largest
disclosed deals involved
investors from the US.
In 2016, Mark Zuckerberg visited Kenya
and he interacted with the tech space.
In 2019, Jack Dorsey also
toured three, four countries
on the continent, was also
planning on actually living
in Africa for six months.
The interest has been there.
What changed was that companies proved
one, that investors
can exit and make money
for their investment.
But secondly, that you're able
to scale on the continent.
The money pouring into
Africa's tech sector
minted five unicorns last year,
a huge number for the ecosystem
given the continent only
has six unicorns so far
and four of those are Nigeria-based.
As far as monetization of tech
and startups is concerned,
Nigeria came in a little bit later,
but has had the hugest success
in terms of monetization.
The African unicorns that we have now
are mainly in Nigeria
because there's money
and an economy to be mobilized there.
One of those unicorns is Flutterwave,
a fintech startup facilitating
cross-border payments.
Africa specifically was
a very complicated market
from a digital payment perspective.
It was a very fragmented
market in the sense
that we had over 50 countries.
We have to date, about 40
currencies in circulation
and over 300 types of digital payments.
And so what Flutterwave
does is pull all of those
different payment types
across the countries,
across currencies onto one platform.
So that as an individual or as a business,
it becomes much easier for
you to reach your customers
or for you to send peer-to-peer
transfers to family members,
friends in other geographies.
Flutterwave caused a lot
of excitement in 2021.
It had not just become a unicorn,
but it became a unicorn in five years,
which was a quite short period of time.
And its founder, Agboola,
really became a go-to person
on how to do it in Africa,
We are focusing on building new products
that will make a very positive impact
on the life of everyone that
comes across those products.
In fact, that's what fintech means to us.
Today over 900,000
businesses use Flutterwave
and over 200 million
individual transactions
have been processed on the platform.
Nigeria is the company's biggest market
but it has ambitious to expand
in Africa and even go global.
We're starting with Egypt and Morocco.
And beyond that, we're also
looking to build a base
outside of Africa.
We're looking at Europe,
we're looking at the U.S.
Eventually, we'll have our
eyes on Canada as well.
So it's really exciting times for us.
But compared with the rest of the world,
African startups are still
much smaller in size.
And while money piles into the continent's
four big tech hubs,
startups in smaller markets,
including those run by women,
are still struggling to secure funding.
Even with a lot of capital coming in,
again, it's chasing very
specific industries,
certain markets.
So if you're kind of not in
those industries, markets
or necessarily have the networks,
which is one of the challenges
a lot of women have.
There's a significant difference
between how much money
is going to all-male founders versus teams
that have women founders or all women.
But we're really talking
about single digits.
We're talking about single digits
of all that investment
actually going to women-led
and women-owned businesses.
We're in a continent
where our digital destiny
is what we're focused on.
And so how do you really think
about adjusting and ensuring
this more equitable distribution
of the economic gains
that we made from this.
Lack of basic infrastructure
and regulations
also create problems for African startups,
those that are looking
to develop their business
and scale up across the continent.
The basics still need work.
For example, in Nigeria, the
need to have access to energy
is something that the government
needs to help facilitate.
Similarly in terms of road
and railway, in majority
of the continent,
are huge investments that
still need to be done.
So that startups that are
working say in logistics
are able to kind of plug into that system.
Regulation is different
across these markets.
Regulation in Kenya is quite
different from regulation
in other countries that we dealing.
And having to deal with
that is quite painful
for a business like us.
Some of the fintechs innovate and then go
to the regulator or innovate
and not aware of the laws.
You're seeing some of the
countries rolling up tax laws
that are targeting such
an emerging industry
where it's e-commerce and so on.
In the nascent stages
of growth, when you tax,
that could limit the potential of it.
While the continent is large
we have a lot of people
on mobile, you have more
people using the internet.
The reality is that it can
be hard to get a good grasp
about the size of the consumer base
that you can really monetize.
We certainly are in a market
with a lot of inequity
and don't have necessarily
the purchasing power
at an average consumer base
that some other markets have.
But starting up in Africa
still has its advantages.
The continent has the youngest
population in the world,
with 70% of sub-Saharan
Africa under the age of 30.
Young Africans provide the continent
with a rich talent pool.
Africa also benefits from a vast diaspora,
an estimated 40 million
people in North America alone.
As someone who was educated
in the US, and the first wave,
I would say when I came back
and many diaspora before me
was coming back to the continent
and physically being here,
starting companies or
working at places like Google
where I worked, the tech companies
that were setting up on the continent.
I think over some time,
what I was starting to see
as a shift is that there's
a lot of opportunities
for the diaspora to not move back,
but to play a role in different ways.
So diaspora who are
investing in tech companies,
some who are advising tech companies,
and I think opens up more opportunities
for this collaboration of diaspora
with those on the continent.
The potential in Africa,
we are just still scratching the surface
and we'll be seeing a lot more growth
in the next five to 10 years.
We are going to have more companies
that are valued at two billion,
four billion, five billion,
10 billion, and even more.
We are going to see some
initial public offerings
from some of these companies.
Tech startups are already
playing a big role
on the continent.
They're creating employment.
They're creating solutions to problems
that are faced by the regular citizenry.
They are providing innovation
that's making ability
to do business easier,
cheaper and more efficient.
In the next few years,
just gonna get better
and easier to do business
on the continent.